my name is Oliver I'm the bad guy Rob
mentioned I'm gonna talk about solving
engineering problems with our PDE tools
and yeah I'm gonna give you a little bit
of an overview
I'm giving another talk this afternoon a
little later is about how to write your
own PDE solvers that's a bit more in
detail you're gonna see a little bit
more code I guess it's probably more for
people that really want to dig in to
delve into the stuff this is bit more of
an overview talk so just that you know a
bit of what we're gonna do so solving
engineering problems that's a huge topic
obviously Wolfram research has a few
products that are in that area their
system mauler and there's been a few and
in the Wolfram language one of the the
tools to use for solving engineering
type problems is of course nd solve the
numerical differential equation solving
tool and D solve and that that's the
thing I'm going to talk about and
dissolve and nd solve itself is probably
one of the most complicated functions
within Mathematica it does a lot of
things so you can solve ordinary
differential equation boundary value
problems delay differential equations
hybrid and discontinuous equations
differential algebraic equations and
partial differential equations and in
the partial differential equations
division you can use a specific method
for solving PDEs of a rectangular
regions or and now that's the new part
of our arbitrary shaped region so we
drill it down a little bit of where my
comfort zone is I'm going to talk about
nd solve over arbitrary shaped regions
so how does that look like you use the
function and D salt value you specify a
PDE operator like the negative laplacian
equal to one you said of a couple of
boundary conditions U is the dependent
variable that we'd like to find the
solution for and you say that on some
parts of the boundary the value U is
supposed to be 0 and on other parts of
the boundary the values supposed to be
and the region is defined by X equal X
comma 0 1 and y 0 1 where Y are the
independent variables and this all will
return you're an interpolating function
and that's an object that you can
immediately use to plot to visualize so
that's the solution of that specific
problem so that's how nd solve worked
has worked in previous versions and
that's exactly the same input you can
use nowadays now in order to solve PDE s
you basically need three things you need
a region over which you like to solve
the PDE you need the PDS a such of
course and you need boundary conditions
and the boundary conditions are kind of
the interface between the region and the
PDE so that's an intermediate layer so
two so to speak in ND solve if we do a
problem set up like that you specify a
region I've just used an arbitrary
region here like a disk you specify an
operator the la la pasión and then we
can have something like a boundary
condition a directly boundary condition
in this case and there in this case you
see I specified that the dependent
variable U is supposed to be 0
and the second argument specifies where
that boundary condition is supposed to
be active so everywhere where X is
larger than 0 0 this boundary condition
is going to be active and then you call
nd solve value again with the operator
the boundary condition as we specified
them and that will return you an
interpolating function and again you
visualize the solution with for example
plot 3d and also note here that again we
specified x and y are part of this
region Omega so that's that's a
principle how how how it works so the
question is which type of PDS can we
actually solve so don't be disappointed
we can only solve one PDE but we'll get
to that so this one PDE is this big
thing up here and you see a second order
time derivative a first order time
derivative a diffusion
of coefficient is a convection operator
another convection operator abounding
and excuse me a load on the Indus PD and
if you look at the PDS I've listed here
those are some of the classical ones and
if you see the blue parts those are the
components so to speak that are active
in these respective PDEs so it's kind of
a lego system where you can combine
different components of PD operators and
build your own PDE together now we're
going to look at a few specific examples
so here I have a poisson type of
equation I want to specify dirichlet
boundary conditions so this is the
region I'm interested in and the red and
the blue mark specify where I want to
place boundary conditions so first I set
up this implicit region which specifies
the region that I want to solve my PDE
over a specified the operator again and
I have to directly boundary condition
one says the dependent is supposed to be
zero and that's the one that's on the
left hand upper side and then I have a
secondary condition that says the value
is supposed to be 100 and that's in the
inner circle part of that specific
region again I call nd salt value with
all the parameters we specified and I
can plot the solution again with plot 3d
same thing again on the boundary we can
specify three different types of
boundary conditions we can specify
directly boundary conditions that what
we saw so far I'm gonna talk about the
normal or we couldn't see examples about
the normal value just now directly
condition means take the dependent
variable and give the dependent very
specific value at that point a Norman
boundary value specifies how much flux
goes over the boundary how much of the
material or whatever you're modeling is
going over a boundary the moment value
that we can specify is something called
a generalized Norman value and yeah I
can show it show examples about that
later if you do not specify anything on
the boundary that defaults to annoying
ones zero boundary condition which means
basically yeah you you have an
insulating wall for example that's what
moment zero means so not specifying
anything means normal zero boundary
condition condition okay the same region
as I had previously and we have two
different boundary conditions now we
have a seriously condition again on the
upper left-hand part and has just
specified anointment value or a
generalized norm and value in this case
here we have minus two times
the dependent variable on this inner
boundary one's inner circle and again nd
solve solve the equation and visualizing
with plot 3d so I've left that away now
here's a 3d example I have I'd like to
model a heat sink so that's that's the
boundary mesh I have here I've used a
finite element specific tool to add
specific markers here so I'll have this
red region and the green region and
those are useful when I want to specify
boundary conditions as I can say I want
a specific boundary condition in this
red region and in the green region makes
it a bit easier sometimes to specify
them in this way we'll see that just now
and the and the equation I want to solve
is a Laplace type of equation okay I
have two Mormon values one is using this
is active on this element marker one
that's one of the regions and the second
one is active on the element market two
and this first one is it's not exactly
it's not too important to understand the
exact physics of this one is just a flux
over the boundary where we specify a
specific Norman value and here we
specify something in relation to the
dependent variable of you the
specification now is I have the PD
operator and set that equal to the
boundary conditions and the reason why
that's done this way will become a
little
become apparent just now then I call nd
solve on that and visualize the solution
so here's now the solution of this
specific PDE problem that specific mesh
had a hundred a little more than a
hundred thousand nodes so that means the
system matrices are a hundred thousand
by a hundred thousand and we solve that
in something like four seconds with nd
solve so it scales fairly well these
could these these PDE Lego components
have something that are coefficients and
these coefficients are there they're
marked in red and discern the slide and
these coefficients may depend on space
and time
they cannot yet depend on the dependent
variable so we cannot yet solve
nonlinear problems with with the finite
element method so what I have here is I
have a rectangular region out of which I
can a piece out and on this inner
boundary I'm going to set a specific
potential and the outer boundary is not
going to have is having a zero potential
and the PD I would like to solve is
something like this
so this epsilon R is a function of x and
y and this epsilon RS you find if Y so
the Y component of this region is
smaller than a specific number I've
specified a specific number that a
specific height that goes through that
region use these material parameters and
if not use those here this is how I
specify the entire PDE I specified
directly conditions on the outside the
dependent is zero and on this inner part
that I cut out I have 10 to the power of
3 when I solve that so again I put that
into nd solve you see the discontinuity
here in the two materials and you see
that there's a kink here in the solution
so nd solve can can actually handle
discontinuities in the coefficients one
thing I'd like to point out
is the fact and that that was what the
question was
in essence about is nd solve actually
sees this coefficient and sees that
there is a discontinuity and
automatically introduces this material
boundary so you don't even have to
specify and these all can analyze the
PDE and see okay this is a different
region and then it's better for myself
to to divide that region so I can come
to a better solution yes there exactly
it's exactly the same it's like just the
way the result is returned is a little
different yeah
okay here's quickly a transient problem
so what you see here is a pipe inside
that pipe you have a hot liquid outside
is I don't know room temperature
whatever and these holes that you see in
in the pipe are cooling ducts and I'm
going to look at this specific
symmetrical section here what I want to
know is like what is the heat
distribution in this pipe when I switch
on the cooling liquid when the cooling
liquid comes inside in this region so I
have an ointment value that is time
dependent now so it says if T smaller
than 10 then I use minus 100 times T I
ramp it up in 10 seconds and the maximum
is minus 1000 that's the amount of heat
that cooling liquid can absorb this is
the the second part is the specification
of there the second part is the
specification of where that region is
active I have to directly condition one
is on the inside
that's the 200 degrees and that one is
on the outsides is 15 degrees this is
the PDE operator again I use nd salt
value as with a time dependent problem
and all right so I'm excuse me so the
first thing i do is i compute myself in
the initial condition at time t 0
because ND solve needs an initial
condition and then I use that initial
condition to start and dissolve value so
and this year is
the solution so now you see at different
times in the solution how the heat is
absorbed when I switch on this this
cooling liquid okay and dissolve so what
okay
what in turn you would nd solve does it
analyzes the coefficients or the input
function you gives it extracts the
necessary components and Auto compiles
does and then then runs yeah yeah it
does it does that that's right
here's the contour plot of the solution
at time 25 okay so let's so we've warmed
up now and now we'll discuss systems of
of PD es so I said that we're only
interested in one PDE that still true
but we can couple as many of them
together as we like in this example I'm
going to show two PDE s coupled together
but they can be arbitrary arbitrary many
what you see now I have the dependent
variable U and the second dependent
variable V so this diffusion coefficient
we have a second diffusion coefficient
and then the second equation we also
have the dependent variable U and the
dependent variable V so you can now
cross couple between these two
coefficients that's a very general way
to express PDE s directly conditions are
now u plus V equals R and Norman values
also now have a U and a V component so
it get it's getting a little more
involved so here's an example from
structural mechanics I have a rectangle
from 0 0 to 5 1
I have young's modulus 10 to the 3 and a
Poisson ratio of 3333 by a hundred I
have a plane stress operator I say so
and that operator works in the dependent
U and the dependent V 1 is the X
direction and one is the Y direction
I have no deformation in the X direction
and in the Y direction I put on the
right hand side on at x equals 5 on the
right hand
Andriy I put a force of minus one unit
in the downward direction and on the
left hand side u and V are held fixed at
a fixed position I call nd solve value
this is a coupled PD it now returns to
interpolating functions and this is the
visualization of the deformed object now
so you see on this right-hand side I've
put a force of minus 1 in the negative y
direction and this is the deformation
now I've written a small function that's
not part of Mathematica right now to
compute the familiar stress so you can
also do something like that
here's an example from fluid flow so
this is a Stokes equation on this
left-hand side we have an inflow
boundary condition in the X direction on
the right hand side we have a pressure
boundary condition we say we specify
specific pressure here these are the
equation two three coupled equations
we're going to solve there in U V and P
U and V are the velocity in the X and
the y direction and P is the pressure I
specified to tomorrow this problem I
specify an implicit region I have this
Stokes flow operator with a coefficient
u V and P and there's no force on that
operator I have directly conditioned
that mom's the inflow condition so you
at the left hand side is specified by
this formula
U and V on all other sides are set to 0
and the pressure at the output is also
set to 0 we call nd solve we give an
interpolation order and this allows us
actually to use a higher order
interpolation for the velocity than we
use for the pressure that's something
very neat because that stabilizes this
specific method this specific for this
specific problem it stabilizes the
computation and here's a visualization
of the flow field in this duct 3d here's
an example from structural mechanics
I have a crankshaft and that's a
graphics object I use the function
discretize graphics and feed that into
this finite element mesh generation tool
that's a hundred and seventy-five
thousand tetrahedra snow I have this
stress operator in three components UV
and W so it's in the XY and z direction
and again I have a force in the seat in
the negative Z direction and there's a
boundary conditions on the left and the
right hand side
nd solve takes about six and a half or
seven seconds on this computer and on
this computer but on a regular laptop
and here's a visualization in red you
see the deformation of the crankshaft
when it has been pushed pushed down but
held in place on the left and right hand
side okay this is all that had been in
there in ten point zero and ten point
one this is new in ten point two we can
solve I can value problems so the single
PDE we've seen before can be solved as a
lambda equals lambda u an eigenvalue
problem and here are a few examples so I
can now the new function that we're
using now is end the eigen system the
negative laplacian U is the dependent
variable from x from zero to 2pi and
give me four eigenvalues these are the
four eigenvalues and i can plot the four
corresponding eigen functions here's a
little bit more of a more complicated
example so now we've changed the region
to a dirt to a disc and also specified a
boundary condition so this is the
constraint eigenvalue problem we say the
dependent variable is zero true means
everywhere on the boundary these are the
corresponding values and this is the
interpolating functions a plot of the
inter that's one of the interpolating
functions and here are some of the plots
of those okay
so this is a picture from Wikipedia and
someone took a mini car and cut it in
half that's what you what you see here
so it's it's it's cotton you can look
inside what I used is the image
processing masking tool and cut out or
made a polygon of what the boundary
that's inside this mini car
I used boundary digitized graphics to
discretize that boundary and I fed that
into eigen system to find the acoustic
modes in that mini car and I wanted to
compute six of those and this now is a
superposition of the first eigen
function in that mini car that gives you
the pressure of the acoustic pressure in
that car on the first eigen eigen
function okay we're going to switch
topic a little bit again this has been
added in 10.3 and that is using PDE s
and events what this means is you can
have an event during a time integration
with PDE s imagine you have a room that
has three solid walls
glass front and over that glass front
the heat is dissipating or coming into
the room depending on the outside
temperature I have an outside
temperature model PI a sine function and
15 degrees plus 10 times the sine this
is the model of the room some material
constants I have an ointment value that
is the outside temperature minus the
dependent variable and now oops
now the event is supposed to trigger if
the temperature in the room goes below
18 degrees or if the temperature goes
above 20 degrees then either the heater
is supposed to be switched on or
switched off and that's been that's done
with a discrete variable and that's the
variable a in this in this example here
so if a equals zero will
set the event time to tea and change a
and in this case here if the event is if
the the evaluation of the function U at
the position is higher than the trigger
time T high or trigger high then we
switch the event off or the the Machine
the heater is switched off this is the
PDE model so the laplacian and this is
the actual heater inside of the region
that's the heater that switched on this
heater is also ramped up and ramped down
so if you switch on a heater in room it
just doesn't produce the heat all or if
you switch it up it's still hot and need
some time to cool down
all these information is then again
plugged into nd solve value it computes
an interpolating function and here's the
result for this specific example so what
you see here in in this orange orange
tone is the outside temperature this is
the twenty degrees mark this is the 18
degrees mark so initially the heaters
off so it switches on it overshoots a
bit starts to switch off and cool down
but since the outside temperature is
still rising the inside the temperature
in the room is also rising only when it
starts to fall down this also begins to
fall down and when it reaches a
temperature that's below 18 degrees the
heater is switched on again it shoots
since the doctor temperature it's night
now
we switch it on and it overshoots again
a bit it switches off and on so you you
see you see that that's kind of the
event switching it on and off okay so
that's basically what I want to say as a
summary I'd say nd solve rocks we can
solve linear the variable coefficient
transient systems of PD es over
arbitrary regions in one two and three
dimensions
my email is Ruben Coe at Wolfram comm
it's not a secret if you work on PD es
or something like that and want to
discuss that with me please send to you
now
thank you for your attention